Лея Артц взагалі-то хотіла поступити на музичний
факультет, але для цього їй забракло балів.
Саме тому дев’ятнадцатирічна мешканка Леверкузена
тепер опиналася на ознайомчому курсі в Бундесвері.
Її скерувли у двадцять першу танкову бригаду
в Ауґустдорфі.
Разом із сусідкою по кімнаті Іділь Лея наводить порядок
у своєму помешканні в казармі. Приймати роботу прийшов
молодший сержант.
Покладіть подушку на іншій бік.
Переверніть її, щоб прорізу не було видно.
Тут ще трохи можна поправити, а так у цілому -
годиться.
У казармах учасники табору
теж проходять стройову підготовку. Але це більше
не супроводжується грубими криками командувачів.
Адже Бундесверу нині доводиться змагатися за молоді кадри
на ринку праці.
Коли ми навчаємо, наш тон подекуди нічим
не відрізняється від тону професора в університеті або професійно-технічному училищі. Тому що ми
насамперед намаємося передати зміст. Сьогодні муштра вже
не в пріоритеті.
Тренінг у наметі, рано вранці, молоді цивільні
ще не зовсім прокинулися. Їм від шістнадцяти до двадцяти років.
Неповнолітним не можна торкатися
зброї, але досвідчені солдати показують
та пояснюють їм усе.
Танкова бригада
охоче показує те, що має: наприклад,
танковий тягач "Буйвол".
А можна залізти всередину?
Круто!
Тут просто море кнопок. І дуже багато
різних приладів. І я геть не розумію, для чого це все.
Тут також є педаль газу і зчеплення,
гадаю, як в автомобілі.
Ця броньована десантно-транспортна вантажівка
викликає у молодих учасників табору дещо
змішані почуття. Їм розповіли,
що Бундесвер купив ці вантажівки після
бомбових нападів на німецьких солдатів
в Афганістані.
Звісно, я не хочу йти на фронт,
є й такі, які хочуть, але я особисто – ні. Але це
частина роботи солдата.
Кульмінаційний момент тижня:
показ зброї танкової бригади.
Бойовий танк Леопард 2 – потужністю у тисяча п'ятсот
кінських сил і вагою у понад шістдесят тонн.
Мотопіхота займає позиції.
Симуляція бойових дій - патруль потрапив у засідку
і під обстріл.
Учасники табору також можуть приєднатися.
Знаєте скільки це важить?
Скільки?
20 кілограмів
Було класно. Подекуди було важко – дуже рано прокидатися і займатися спортом.
Але трохи активності – це, як на мене, добре.
Ознайомлення з військовою справою було справді класним. Хай там як,
але я багато чого довідалася та просунулася далі
у своєму рішенні.
Лейа хоче спочатку пройти добровільну військову службу,
потім вчитися в університеті і зрештою поступити
на офіцерську службу. Трохи складний шлях.
Утім, Бундесвер має бути гнучким і відкритим
для нових кар’єрних шляхів.